the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
today we're going to hold off just a
little bit on boiling water and talk
about another application of integrals
and we'll get to the the witch's
cauldron in the middle the thing that
I'd like to start with today is average
value this is something that I mentioned
a little bit earlier and there was a
misprint on the board so I want to make
sure that we have the definition
straight and also the reasoning straight
this is one of the most important
applications of integrals one of the
most important examples if you take the
average of a bunch of numbers that looks
like this and we can view this as
sampling a function as we would with a
Riemann sum and what I said last week
was that this tends to this expression
here which is called the continuous
average so this guy is the continuous
average or just the average of F and I
want to explain that just to make sure
that we're all on the same page in
general if you have a function and you
want to interpret the integral our first
interpretation was that it's something
like the area under the curve but
average value is another reasonable
interpretation namely if you take
equally spaced points here starting with
x0 x1 x2 all the way up to X N which is
the left point B and then we have values
y1 which is f of X
one y2 which is f of x2 all the way up
to yn which is f of X M and again the
spacing here that we're talking about is
B minus a over N all right so remember
that spacing that's going to be the
connection that will draw then the
Riemann sum is y1 through yn the sum of
y1 through yn multiplied by Delta X and
that's what tends is Delta X goes to 0
to the integral the only change in point
of view if I want to write this limiting
property which is right above here you
only change between here and here is
that I want to divide by the length of
the interval B minus a so I will divide
by B minus a here and divide by B minus
a over here
and then just check what this thing
actually is Delta X divided by B minus a
what is that factor well if we look over
here to what Delta X is it's if you
divide by B minus a it's 1 over N so the
fact or Delta X divided by B minus a is
1 over n that's what I put over here the
sum of y1 through yn divided by N and as
this tends to 0 it's the same as n going
to infinity those are the same things so
the average value in the integral are
very closely related there's only this
difference that we're dividing by the by
the length of the interval I want to
give an example which is an incredibly
simple-minded one but it will come into
play later on so let's take the example
of a constant
and this is I hope will make you
slightly less confused about what I just
wrote as well as making you think that
this is as simple-minded and reasonable
as it as it should be if I check what
the average value of this constant is
its given by this relatively complicated
formula here that is I have to integrate
the function C well it's just the
constant C and however you do this as an
antiderivative as thinking it as a
rectangle the answer that you're going
to get is C here so work that out the
answer is C and so the fact that the
average of C is equal to C which had
better be the case for averages explains
the denominator explains the one over B
minus a there that's cooked up exactly
so that the average of a constant is
what it's supposed to be otherwise we
have the wrong normalizing factor we've
clearly got a piece of nonsense on our
hands and incidentally it also explains
the 1 over N in the preview in the very
first formula that I wrote down the
reason why this is called the average or
one reason why it's the right thing is
that if you took the same constant C for
Y all the way across there n times if
you divided by n you get back C that's
what we mean by average value and that's
why the and it's there all right so that
was a an easy example now none of the
examples that we are getting give are
going to be back all that complicated
but they will get sort of steadily more
sophisticated the second example is
going to be the average height of a
point on a semicircle
and maybe I'll draw a picture of the
semicircle first here and we'll just
make it the one the standard circle the
unit circle so maybe I should have
called it a unit semicircle this is the
point negative 1 this is the point 1 and
we're picking a point over here and
we're going to take the typical or the
average height here integrating with
respect to DX so sort of continuously
with respect to DX well what is that
well according to the rule it's 1 over B
minus a times these sorry it's it's it's
up here in the box one of our B might
say the interval from A to B f of X DX
that's 1 over plus 1 minus minus 1 the
integral from negative 1 to 1 square
root of 1 minus x squared DX all right
because the height is is y is equal to
right this is y is equal to the square
root of 1 minus x squared and to
evaluate this is not as difficult as it
seems this is 1/2 times this quantity
here which we can interpret as an area
it's the area of the semicircle all
right so this is the area of the
semicircle which we know to be half the
area of the circle so it's PI over 2 and
so the answer here the average height is
PI over 4 now later in the class and
actually not in this unit we'll actually
be able to calculate the antiderivative
of this so in other words we'll be able
to calculate this analytically for right
now we just have the geometric reason
why it's why the value of this is PI
over 2 and we'll do that in the fourth
unit when we do a lot of techniques of
integration
all right so here's an example turns out
the average height of this is is PI over
4 now the next example that I want to
give it introduces a little bit of
confusion and I'm not going to resolve
this confusion completely but I'm going
to try to get you used to it I'm going
to take the average height again but now
with respect to to arc length which is
usually denoted theta now this brings up
an extremely important feature of
averages which is that you have to
specify the variable with respect to
which the average is taking place and
the answer will be different depending
on the variable so it's not going to be
the same well can't spell the word
length here just like the plural of
witches last time well we'll work on
that we'll fix all of our that's that's
an ancient Gaelic word I think length
okay all right so now so now let me show
you that it's not quite the same here
it's especially exaggerated if maybe I
shift this this little interval DX over
to the to the to the right-hand end then
you can see that the little portion that
corresponds to it which is the D theta
piece has a different length from the DX
piece and indeed as you come down here
these very short portions of DX length
have much longer portions of theta
length so that the the the average that
we're taking when we do it with respect
to theta is going to emphasize the low
values more they're going to be more
exaggerated and the average should be
lower then then the average that we got
here so you should expect a different
number and it's not going to be PI over
4 it's going to be something else
whatever it is it should be small
than PI over four now let's set up the
the integral the integral follows the
same rule it's just one over the length
of the interval times the integral over
the interval of the function it's the
integral but now where it is theta range
this time theta goes from 0 to PI so the
integral is from 0 to PI and the thing
we divide by is is PI and the
integration requires us to know the
formula for the height which is sine
theta in terms of theta of course it's
the same as square root of 1 minus x
squared but it's interesting in terms of
theta
so it's this and here's our here's our
average okay sorry I'll put this this up
here so that's the the formula for the
height all right so let's work it out
this one we have the advantage of being
able to work out because we know the
antiderivative of sine theta
it happens with this factor pi it's it's
negative cosine theta all right
and so that's negative 1 over pi times
cosine pi sorry cosine PI minus cosine 0
which is a negative 1 over pi times
negative 2 which is 2 divided by pi
which is second and sure enough if you
check it you'll see that 2 over pi is
less than PI over 4 because pi squared
is bigger than 8 yeah question
the question is how did I get sine theta
and the answer is on this diagram if
theta is over here then this height is
this and this is the angle theta then
the height is the sine okay another
question yeah the question is what is
the first one the first one is average
of height of a point on the semicircle
and this one is with respect to X so
what this reveals is that it's ambiguous
to say what the average value something
is unless you've explained what the
underlying averaging variable is
what then the next question is how
should you interpret this this value
that is what came out of this
calculation and the the answer is only
sort of embedded in this calculation
itself if you if you so here's a way of
thinking of it which is anticipating our
next subject which is probability which
is suppose you picked a number at random
in this interval with equal likelihood
one place in another and then you saw
what height was above that that would be
the interpretation of this first average
value and the second one is I picked
something at random on this circle and
equally likely any possible point on
this circle according to its length and
then I and then I asked what the height
of that point is and those are just
different things another question
cosine of pi shouldn't it be zero no
cosine if it's negative one cosine of PI
is negative 1 cosine sorry
yeah no cosine of zero is one cosine of
PI is negative one and so they cancel
that it is they don't cancel it's minus
1 minus 1 which is minus 2
keypoint all right yeah all right let me
let me repeat so the question is the
question was to repeat the reasoning by
which I guessed in advance that probably
this was going to be the relationship
between the average value with respect
to arc length versus the average value
with respect to this horizontal distance
all right and it had to do with the
previous way this diagram was drawn
which is comparing an interval in DX
with an interval in in theta a little
section in theta and when you're near
the top they're nearly the same that is
it's more or less balanced it's a little
curved here they're a little different
but here it becomes very exaggerated the
D theta lengths are much longer than the
DX lengths which means that the
importance given by the theta variable
to these parts of the circle is larger
relative to these parts whereas if you
look at this section versus this section
for the DX they give equal weights to
these two equal lengths but here with
respect to theta this is relatively
short and this is much larger so as I
say D theta variables emphasizing the
lower parts of the semicircle more
that's because this length is shorter
and this length is longer whereas these
two are the same it's a it's a balancing
act of the relative weights I'm going
I'm going to say that again in a
different way and maybe maybe this
little the lower part is more important
for theta so the question is but
shouldn't it have a bigger value because
it's a longer length never with averages
whatever the length is we're always
dividing we're always compensating by
the total we have the integral from 0 to
PI but we're dividing by PI here we had
the integral from minus 1 to 1 but we're
dividing by 2 so we divide by something
different each time and this is very
very important it's that the average of
a constant is that same constant
regardless of which one we did so if it
were a constant we would always
compensate for the length so the length
never matters see if it's if it's the
integral from 0 to 1 million or a
hundred let's say 1 over 100 C DX it's
just the same it's always that C it
doesn't matter how long it is because we
compensate all right that's really the
difference between an integral and an
average is that we're dividing by the
total all right now I want to introduce
another notion which is actually what's
underlying these two two examples that I
just just wrote down and this is by far
the one in which you should emphasize
most in your in your thoughts because it
is much more flexible and and is much
more typical of real-life problems so
the idea of a weighted average is the
following you take the integral say from
A to B of some function but now you
multiply by a weight and you have to
divide by the total and what's the total
going to be it's the integral from A to
B of this total weighting that we have
now why is this the correct notion I'm
going to explain it to you in two ways
the first is this very simple-minded
thing that I wrote on the board there
with the constants
what we want is the average value of C
to be C otherwise this makes no sense as
an average now let's just look at this
definition here and see that that's
correct if you integrate C from A to B W
of X DX and you divide by the integral
from A to B W of X DX not surprisingly
the C factors out it's a constant so
this is C times the integral A to B W of
X DX divided by the same thing and
that's why we picked it we picked it so
that these things would cancel and this
would give C all right that's that's the
this so in the previous case this
property explains the denominator and
again over here it explains the
denominator now let me just give you one
more explanation which is maybe a a
real-life pretend real-life example you
have a stock that you bought for ten
dollars of one year and then six months
later you bought some more for twenty
dollars and then you bought some more
for thirty dollars all right now what's
the average price of your stock well it
depends on how many shares you bought if
you bought this many shares the first
time and this many shares the second
time and this many shares the third time
this is the total amount that you spent
and the total price sorry the average
price is the total price divided by the
total number of shares and this is the
discrete analog of this continuous
averaging process here the function f
now so I use W for weight the function f
now is the function whose values are 10
20 and 30 and the waiting's are the
relative importance of the different
purchases
all right so again these W eyes or
weights all right ice there was another
question out in the audience at some
point over here yes right very very good
point so in the in this in this part in
this numerator here this statement is in
this example we factored out C but here
we cannot factor out f of X that's
that's extremely important and that is
the whole point so in other words the
average the weighted average is very
interesting when because it's you have
to do two different integrals to figure
it out for in general when it happens
that this is C it's an extremely boring
integral which in fact because it's an
average you don't even have to calculate
it all factored it out and cancel these
things and never bother to calculate
these two numbers so these massive
numbers just cancel it so it's very
special property of a constant that it
factors out alright that was our first
discussion and now with this example I'm
going to go back to the to the heating
up of the witch's cauldron and we'll use
average value to illustrate the integral
that we get in that context as well
I remind you let's see the situation
with witch's cauldron was this the first
important thing is that there were all
right whoops let's let's so this is the
big cauldron here this is the one whose
height is one meter and whose width is
two meters and it's a parabola of
revolution here and it had about
approximately 1600 liters in it this
curve was was y equals x squared and the
situation that I described at the end of
last time was that the initial
temperature was t is equal to zero
degrees celsius and the final
temperature instead of being a constant
temperature we were we were heating this
guy up from the bottom and it was hotter
on the bottom then on the top and the
final temperature was given by the
formula T is equal to a hundred minus 30
times the height Y so at y equals zero
at the bottom it's a hundred and at the
top T is just equal to 70 degrees okay
so this is the the final configuration
for the temperature and the question was
how much energy do we need
so so the first observation here and
this is the the reason for giving this
example is that it's important to
realize that you want to use the method
of disks in this case the reason so it
doesn't have to do with you shouldn't
think of the disks first but what you
should think of is the horizontal we
must use horizontals because T is
constant on horizontals it's not
constant on verticals if we set things
up with shells as we did last time to
compute the volume of this then T will
vary along the shell and we won't be it
will still have an averaging problem an
integral problem along the vertical
portion but if we do it this way T is
constant on this whole level here and so
there's no more calculus involved in
calculating what the contribution is of
any given level so T is a constant on
horizontals actually in disguise this is
that same trick that we have here we can
factor constants out of integrals you
could view it as an integral but the
point is that it's more elementary than
that all right now I have to set it up
for you and in order to do that I need
to remember what the equation is which
is y equals x squared and the formula
for the total amount of energy is going
to be a volume times the number of
degrees that's going to be equal to the
energy that we need here and so let's
add it up it's the integral from 0 to 1
and this is with respect to Y so the Y
level goes from 0 to 1 is top levels y
equals upon this bottom levels y equals
0 and the disk that we get this is the
point X comma Y here is rotated around
and its radius is X so the thickness is
dy and the area of the disk is PI x
squared and the thing that we're
averaging is T well we're not yet
averaging we're just integrating it
we're just adding up the total now I'm
just going to plug in the various values
for this and what I'm going to get is T
again is a hundred minus 30y and this
radius is measured up to this very end
so x squared is y so this is PI Y and Y
and this is the integral that we'll be
able to evaluate yeah question all right
let's carry this out let's finish off
the calculation here let's see this is
equal to what is it equal to well I'll
put it over here it's equal to 50 PI Y
squared minus right because this is a
hundred PI Y and then there's a 30 right
this is this is a hundred PI Y minus 30
PI Y squared and I have to take the
antiderivative of that so I get 50 PI Y
squared and I get a 10 PI Y cubed
evaluated at 0 and 1 and that is a 40 pi
now I spent a tremendous amount of time
last time focusing on units because I
want to tell you how to get a realistic
number out of this and there's a there's
a subtle point here that I that I
pointed out last time they had to do
with changing meters to centimeters I
claim that I've treated those correctly
so what we have here is that the answer
is in degrees that is Celsius times
cubic meters these are the correct units
and now I can translate this into a
Celsius is spelled with a see there
that's interesting Celsius I can
translate this it into into units that
you're more familiar with so let's try
40 pi degrees times meters cubed and
then do the conversion factors first of
all there's one calorie per degree times
a milliliter that's one conversion and
then let's see I'm going to have to
translate from centimeters so I have
here a hundred centimeters per meter
cubed so these are the two conversion
factors that I need and so I get 40 pi
times 10 to the 6 that's 100 cubed and
this is in calories right so how much is
this well it's a little better maybe to
do it in 40 pi times the thousand
kilocalories because these are the ones
that you actually see on your nutrition
labels of foods and so so this number is
around 125 or so let's see that about
right
let's make sure I've got these numbers
right yeah this is about 125 40 times pi
and so so one candy bar this is a
Halloween example one candy bar is about
250 kilocalories all right so this is a
half a candy bar so the answer to our
question
is that it takes takes 500 candy bars to
heat up this this thing yeah okay so
that's that's our
that's our example now yeah question sit
again what does the integral give us
this integral is the integral represents
the following thing so the question is
what does this integral give us so
here's the integral here it is rewritten
so that it can be calculated and what
this integral is giving us is the
following thing you have to imagine the
following idea you've got a little chunk
of water in here and you're going to
raise it from 0 degrees all the way up
to whatever the target temperature is
and so that little milliliter of water
if you like has to be raised from 0 to
some number which is a function of the
height it's something between 70 and a
hundred degrees and the one right above
it also has to be raised to a
temperature although a slightly
different temperature and what we're
doing with the integrals we're adding up
all of those degrees and the calorie
represents how much it takes one calorie
represents how much it takes to raise by
one degree one milliliter of water one
cubic centimeter of water that's the
definition of a calorie
and we're adding it up so in other words
each of these cubes is one thing and now
we have to add it up over this massive
thing which is 1600 liters and we have a
lot of different little cubes and that's
what we did when we when we glom to them
all together that's what the integral is
doing for us
other questions all right now I want to
connect this with with weighted averages
before we before we go on because that
was the reason why I did weighted
averages first I'm going to compute also
the average final temperature so final
because that this is the interesting one
the average starting temperature is very
boring it's zero the average final
temperature is it's that individually
the temperatures are different and the
answer here is it's the integral from
zero to one of T times pi Y dy divided
by the integral from zero to one of pi Y
dy so this is the total temperature
weighted appropriately to the volume of
water that's involved at that
temperature divided by the total volume
of water and we computed these two
numbers the number in the numerator is
what we called 40 pi and the number in
the denominator actually this is it this
is easier than what we did last time
with shells you can just look at this
and see that it's the area under a
triangle it's PI over 2 and so the
answer here is 80 degrees this is the
average temperature note that this is a
weighted average the weighting here is
different according to the height that
the weighting factor is pi times y
that's the weighting factor and that's
not surprising there's when Y is small
there's less volume down here up above
those are more important volumes because
there's more water up at the top of the
cauldron than there is down at the bar
of the cauldron if you compare this to
the ordinary average if you take a
maximum temperature plus the minimum
temperature divided by two that would be
a hundred plus seventy divided by two
you would get 85 degrees and that's
bigger why because the cooler water is
on top and the actual average the truly
correct weighted average is lower than
the than this fake average which is not
the the true average of in this context
all right so the weighting is is that
the thing is getting fatter near the top
alright so now I'm going to do another
example of weighted average and this
example is also very much worth your
while it's the other incredibly
important one in interpreting integrals
and it's a very very simple example of a
function f the waiting's will be
different but the functions f will be of
a very particular kind namely the
function f will be practically being a
constant but not quite it's going to be
a constant on one interval and then zero
on the rest so we'll do those weighted
averages now this subject is called
probability
in in probability what we do though I'm
going to just going to give some
examples here I'm going to pick a point
in quotation marks at random in the
region y less than X less than 1 minus x
squared that's this this shape here well
let's draw it up here
let's draw it right down here for now so
somewhere in here some some point X
comma Y and then I need to tell you
according to what this random really
means this is a proportional to area if
you like proportional to area so area
inside of the section and then the
question that we're going to answer
right now is what is the chance that or
it's called usually called probability
that X is bigger than 1/2
now let me show you that this what's
going on here and this is always the
case with things in probability so first
of all we have a name for this this is
called the probability that X is bigger
than 1/2 and so that's what it's called
and in our notation here and what it is
is the probability is always equal to
the part divided by the whole it's a
ratio just like the one over there and
which is the part in which is the whole
well in this picture it's the whole is
the whole parabola and the part is the
section X bigger than 1/2 and it's just
the ratio of those two areas let's write
that down
that's the integral from 1/2 to 1 of 1
minus x squared DX divided by the
integral from negative 1 to 1 1 minus x
squared DX
and again the weighting factor here is 1
minus x squared and to be a little bit
more specific here the int the starting
point a is negative 1 and the end point
is is plus 1 all right so this is the
probability that X is less than 1/2 and
if you work it out its it turns out to
be five eighteenth's we won't do it all
right yeah
what we're trying to do with probability
so so I can't repeat your question but I
can try to try to say because it was a
little bit too complicated but it was
not correct okay what we're taking is we
have two possible things that could
happen either let's put it this way
let's let's make it a gamble somebody
picks a point in here at random and went
and and that we're trying to figure out
what your chances are of winning in
other words a chance that the person
picks it something in here versus
something in there all right and the
interesting thing is so what percent of
the time do you do you win
the answer is it's some fraction of one
in order to figure that out I have to
figure out the total area here versus
the total of the entire all the way from
minus one to one the beginning to the
end
all right so in the numerator I put
success and in the denominator I put all
possibilities so that right and that
that's the interpretation of this so
maybe I didn't understand your question
why is one minus x squared the weighting
factor that has to do with how you
compute areas under curves the curve
here is y is equal to one minus x
squared and so in order to calculate how
much area is between a half and one I
have to integrate that's the
interpretation of this this is the area
under that curve this integral and the
denominators the area under the whole
thing okay
yeah another question
ah yikes it was supposed to be the same
question is over here thank you this has
something to do with weighting factors
here's the weight factor well it's the
relative importance from the point of
view of this probability of these places
versus those that is so that this is a
weighting factor because it's telling me
that in some sense this number five
eighteenth's yeah actually that makes me
think that this number is probably wrong
well I'll let you calculate it out it
looks like it should be less than 1/4
here because there's this is a quarter
of the total distance and there's a
little less in here than there is in the
middle so in fact it probably should be
less than 1/4 the answer the equation of
the curve is 1 minus x squared
it's the reason why it's the weighting
factor is that we're interpreting and
the question has to do with the area
under that curve and so this is showing
us how much is relatively important
versus how much is not this is these
parts are relatively important these
parts are less important according to
area because we said that area is the
way we're making the choice all right so
I don't have quite enough time to tell
you about my next example instead I'm
just going to tell you what the general
formula is and we'll do our example next
time I'll tell you what it's going to be
so here's the the general formula for
probability here
we're going to imagine that where are we
have a total range wishes maybe going
from A to B and we have some
intermediate values x1 and x2 and then
we're going to try to compute the
probability that some variable that we
picked at random occurs between x1 and
x2 and by definition we're saying that
it's an integral it's the integral from
X 1 to X 2 of the weight DX divided by
the integral all the way from A to B of
the way so again this is the part
divided by the whole and the
relationship between this and the
weighted average that we had earlier was
that the function f of X is kind of a
strange function it's it's 0 & 1 it's
just the picture if you like is that you
have this this weighting factor and it's
going from A to B but then in between
there we have the part that we're
interested in which is between X 1 and X
2 and it's the ratio of this inner part
to the whole thing that we're interested
in all right
tomorrow I'm going to try to do a
realistic example and I'm going to tell
you what it is but we'll take it up
tomorrow it's the following and Shh I
told you it was going to be tomorrow but
we still have a whole minute so I'm
going to tell you what the problem is so
this is going to be a target practice
problem all right you have a target here
and you're throwing darts at this target
and so so you're throwing darts at this
target and somebody is standing next to
the dartboard your little brother is
standing next to the dartboard here and
the question is how likely you are to
hit your little brother so this will
you'll see you'll see whether you like
that or not actually I was the little
brother so I don't know which way you
want to go will go either way we'll find
out next time